always appreciate this man coming on
i've known him for quite some time my
former colleague with
nfl network now doing his
due diligence every day as well as some
great work for the
mmqb sports illustrated's albert breer
how you doing albert
i'm doing great rich how are you doing
i'm better for talking to you i really
am that's a fact
um well i appreciate it no i mean why do
you guys laugh
you know how i feel that about albert
it's true it's absolutely true no it's
just the way you said it all right let's
talk urban meyer albert what's he doing
what's going on with him right now
what's good what's going on with uh
with urban in jacksonville well i'll
tell you
i think it's an interesting move to to
go and bring in tebow and
you know i i'll be honest like i i don't
know
that the upside here is really worth
kind of what you're going to go through
um you know i've talked to some former
players about this
you know i've talked to some people
who've worked with urban um
and i guess the upside is that you have
a messenger for your program
now you know inside the building and you
have a messenger inside your locker room
and a guy who can kind of
tell the players you know what urban
expects and
um you help him set a standard i like to
me though
the problem really is it's twofold it's
number one
you know does this open the door for
every x player who's played for urban
who might be in the fringes of the
league coming and looking for a job
you know and then and then number two um
does he bring a circus with him
um and so you know i i just i like i i
m where i struggle with this rich is
he's 33 years old he's never played the
position before
i i don't think anybody thinks he's
gonna turn into tony gonzalez right like
so
i like like what really are you getting
out of this
outside of you know maybe what you could
get with a lower profile play
player who maybe played for you at ohio
state or florida that's a thing and so
um and look there's nothing against
tebow either um you know i think it's
you know it's amazing what he's
accomplished you know as an athlete a
lot of people didn't think he played
quarterback in the nfl he went to
playoff game
um you know a lot of people laughed at
him at the idea of him playing baseball
and i think he represented himself
pretty well doing that so
i don't you know i don't begrudge him
you know taking the shot at
doing this um you know because you're
your body's only young once but i just
i i i guess i'm sort of failing to see
where the real upside is here for
jacksonville and doing this well how
about let's let's game it out here
albert because i
i don't know about the whole circus
aspect of it that was ten years ago
number one
they'll be in there'll be a level of
interest that's for sure
um and you know uh let's see how urban's
nfl team looks it could look a lot like
belichick's which is like you may want
to make it a circus
it's not gonna happen here you know good
luck good luck trying to reach tebow
trying to get to him he'll be
available maybe once you know to you
but you know um you know there won't be
a
a you know weekly tebow confab for you
in the media
he might place the belichick velvet
ropes around it and suck the life out of
a story in the same way that new england
does that could happen and two
you know urban uh you know better than
most yeah
he's probably like damn straight that
the culture actually
is important for me to install that here
i'm gonna get somebody here my first go
around in the nfl who's been in the nfl
but
also knows exactly what i'm about let
him do that and
also on top of it um you know
uh the owners in terms of a circus
they they were on the aew man like so i
i
know what you know what i mean and and
and and i know i'm with you
and and and they also want to make sure
that they're known internationally i
i think this works on every possible
level that's the way i look at it well
it's good
it's good for business for us for sure
um you know i i
i i would say that like i think it's a
little bit different dynamic
um you know where they are
geographically
um and you know being in foxborough and
having so many other stars there and all
those pelts on the wall
i think it became a little bit easier it
was a little easier for belichick to
control it
i mean rich they're 90 minutes from
gainesville i believe right
i mean it's going to be a big story now
if you want to play devil's advocate of
it
on it i think one thing that's sort of
interesting and i think it was bobby
carpenter who brought this
up to me i mean it was a really really
interesting idea
was doesn't this take pressure off of
trevor
which i thought was sort of an
interesting way of looking at it like
that
maybe because tebow's there it sort of
takes some of the heat off of trevor
and trevor can kind of maybe develop in
a more conventional environment
you know as a young quarterback so that
was sort of an interesting piece of it
um you know and i do know that how urban
urban values culture
and so that's you know i can certainly
see where you know you would want to you
know
sell the culture if you're him um i just
you know again like the guy's not going
to make the team rich or
guys look at him and guys look at it and
and he can't play
i mean wouldn't you think that that
could like hurt from a credibility
no question about it that's the thing i
want to that's the
the last i guess cycle of this
conversation i want to go through with
you albert brewer sports illustrated
um is that you know there's no guarantee
he's going to make the team give him a
shot
you know what i mean like that it's not
like they're signing him to the 53-man
roster here
you know and it's going to cost the
money if he doesn't make it like
that's not the deal that correct that's
not the deal that they have with him
and and and in terms of pressure like
you know no not to push back against an
ohio state guy
uh who's quoting an ohio state guy who
knows the ohio state guy very well
combined but i mean take pressure off
trevor lawrence i don't understand that
what wasn't
you know the cover story in your
magazine prior to the draft that made so
much news
about the fact that he doesn't feel
pressure like he's not normal that's
true where he comes from like that's
true now we're
now we're signing tim tebow i i just
don't think it's a five-game dement
five-dimensional level you know 4d chess
here
i think that this is this is urban
saying you know if you're on the team
uh it's because i say so i run this shop
here
and i want somebody who knows the
culture or you know i'm giving a guy a
shot
that's the way i do it that's the way
i've always done it and i'm a loyal guy
there's people who are loyal to me and
you know and if tebow makes it what a
great story and if you tell shad khan we
want to sign tebow what do you think
he's gonna i'm concerned about the
circus
or or they want to see if he's going to
go against chris jericho you know what i
mean like
you know i mean right let's see if cody
rhodes could use them you know what i
mean
honestly i think that's the way they
might be thinking about it
well i mean look and you're and you know
what you're right like one of the things
that like
i think we sometimes forget like looking
at some of these things in retrospect i
mean i
i like yeah like there was a lot going
on in foxborough
um you know when when tebow was on the
roster there
on the 90 man roster um uh
obviously there were a lot of different
things going on there um
you know but i i think like like like i
i i think if you look at that season i
mean they went to the afc championship
game so it's not like i mean to me like
that that was more of like a four-week
story
right and then the the months to follow
it's like
kind of forgotten you know even though
we all remember it now and same with the
eagles like people like
like i wonder how many people up there
would out there would be able to tell
you
that he was even on the eagles i just
you know by the way you just
training camp and albert you just
reminded me of that you just reminded me
of that i totally forgotten
it's on the eagles chip kelly brought
him in in 2015
and yeah chip got fired at the end of
that year but was that a factor in him
no it wasn't a factor in the season so
you know you're probably right about
that it's a fun thing to talk about in
may
but you know if he doesn't make the team
at the end of august you know we're
probably
not talking about it in october albert
breer here on the rich eisen show
um walk me through what you know about
aaron rodgers one of the
uh more fascinating parts of your column
that came out on monday morning
monday morning quarterback was the
timeline you have for rogers and
what do you know what can you tell us
what do you got for me on this front
here yeah i still think i still think uh
i still think communication is the issue
here
um and i think this goes back to the
communication before the 2020 draft
and you know i i i think if the packers
had called aaron a week ahead of time or
five days ahead of time or even two days
ahead of time
and said hey look heads up we really
like the utah state quarterback
are we going to take them i don't know
but we just want to put this on your
radar
i think the tone and tenor of this whole
thing would be a lot different
than it has wound up being because
it caught aaron off guard and because
they called him the night of the draft
and told him then and so you know i
really think communication
has been at the heart of the problem all
along
and you know i think rather than
sitting down and having a summit over
like okay like this is how we want to
approach the off-season this is what
we're going to do and i'm not
advocating for a quarterback to run a
team they're
the general managers head coaches are
more qualified to do that than
quarterbacks but
i think just an acknowledgement of who
he is for the franchise
and bringing him in and saying listen
like x y and z here's the plan
like just so you know um you know i
don't there's any harm in that
especially when a guy's
you know 38 years old you know it may be
different if you're talking about 23
24 year old quarterback it's something
else when you're talking about a 38 year
old quarterback you know and so
i honestly don't think there's there
would have been any harm in any of that
um so that's the first piece of it the
communication piece and then i think the
second piece is pretty simple um
you know i think aaron looked around and
you know after losing that championship
game
uh like he looks at the other three
quarterbacks he's how aggressive the
chiefs have been around the home sees
how aggressive the bills have been
around
allen most of all sees the way the bucks
have built around brady
and says i say anything i really want
that and i think it's had an effect on a
lot of quarterbacks to be honest with
you rich
it's not just that brady did it and went
to tampa and they built aggressively it
said it worked
and so you know i think your aaron
rodgers and your russell wilson's of the
world are now looking around
and saying that's what i'm up against
you know and i think that that's why
you've sort of
seen wandering eyes from so many
quarterbacks this offseason
and um so i think you add the
communication piece to it
um to to the whole team building aspect
and being aggressive and mortgaging
contracts and
doing what you can to win right now big
add those two things together
and i think you get to where the
discontent is and
i think if they're going to uh fix it
the communication is going to be key
over the next eight weeks down to the
mini camp's a big deal
i think where the rubber meets the road
really is the start of training camp no
doubt i agree with you
there albert so what what is the issue i
mean we had peter king on yesterday or
you're uh you've succeeded him in the
mmqb um
and he says it's not about the contract
it's about something else devonte adams
who
succeeded you on the radio show tv show
known as the herd on colleen with colin
cowherd yesterday
saying that uh there's some things that
they're that
he he's been wanting from the front
office or something along those lines
what is it what is the it here that's at
at play
i the best you can tell i think it's i i
i think it's
i think it's being all in to win right
now um and i think it's sort of the same
thing
you know like the in a certain way that
far ran into
in 2006 2007 2008 where the packers
have done some done things away i mean
really going back to the beginning of
ron wolf so we're talking about 1991
and to their credit it's worked for them
they've been a consistent contender
for you know 30 years doing it this way
um
you know i i i i think you know
you you look at it and it works and
that's fine for most players
but if you're a quarterback in the
twilight of his career and you say okay
i've got two or three more shots left at
this
and you know you see what you're up
against and again you look over at tampa
and they're doing the opposite they're
mortgaging every contract they're
basically saying
we don't care what happens in 2023.
we've got tom brady right now and we're
looking to build around tom brady right
now and win championships right now and
we'll worry about that when we get to it
you know you can understand where like i
think for aaron it's a little bit like
like that's what i want like i want
somebody to build around me that way
and i'll give you this little kind of
nugget here
there's a trigger in his contract that
there's a trigger in his contract
they don't have to ask permission they
can just do it all they have to do is
pull the trigger
and they can turn basically 13 million
dollars on his base salary
into a signing bonus that would save
them
a million dollars off the cap they can
do that today if they want they could
have done that three months ago
they never did it rich and the fact that
that didn't happen
i think it's a kind of an interesting
detail in this whole thing
because that's exactly how the bucks
have made this work
and building around brady they've
continued to mortgage contracts how much
have you heard
from tampa about dummy years right and
pushing money forward
and like i think the packers
again like it's hard to chris as a team
building philosophy because it's worked
for 30 years
but i think the packers you know kind of
i guess i guess feeling we have to do it
this way
and this is the way that we've always
done it and not bending
to adjust for aaron rodgers age
is is a huge part of this and then you
add to the fact that you know
again you go back to jordan love being
picked in the first round and
aaron rodgers saying well that could
have been somebody to help me and you
know that guy is never going to help me
win a championship
and i think you get to where where you
need to be as far as why this is
where it is well and then you know we
had jason light on yesterday albert
um and i try to pick his brain as best i
could with whatever he could share
with me about you know his relationship
with brady
and you know as you know interviewing
general managers as long as you have
asking a question like that if somebody
on live tv and radio is fraught a bit
because you know it could be construed
as well i'm i'm handing the keys to the
store over to brady and letting him be
the general manager it can be viewed
that way
he he was very honest he was saying like
for instance with geo bernard he said
they were thinking of signing him he
texted brady he said hey
you know i'm thinking of signing geo
bernard and he got a text right back
from brady saying great love that guy
so he kind of did run it up the flagpole
and it does make
sense to do that because if i'm building
a team right here from my show
you're building a team for your world
and you're
generating your content albert you're
gonna reach out to people and say i'm
thinking i hire this person
what do you think you know because if
they're valuable to you it kind of does
make sense
and it doesn't seem like rogers is
getting that and
it's interesting what can you again just
what about that nugget about his
contract how does that inform
the relationship in a way that they they
could have
done that and then use that money to
actually build around him now and they
chose not to do it because they don't
like mortgaging right in the future is
that what you're saying
is that what it is yeah if you look at
break if you look at brady's contract
brady's contract mortgage to the hill
like they're gonna have to there's gonna
be a bill waiting for
the bucks whenever brady walks out the
door and they're fine with it you know
and then you look at some of their other
contracts um you know and dominic and
sue's new contract
uh rob gronkowski's new contract levante
david's new contract all these guys that
they brought back
right yes um to kind of bring the band
back together all of those contracts are
mortgaged as well well why are they
mortgaged because that's the only way
that they can make
everybody that's the only way that they
can make everybody happy financially and
keep everybody in house
and eventually it's like credit cards
you know like
all of that's going to come due at some
point and the packers just
as a rule haven't done that they've
always had very clean contracts
um you know and and i the reason why i
think that triggers an interesting
detail is not only will the packers not
do it with other people's contracts
they won't do it they're not doing it
with aaron's contract you know
i mean the guy who would want you to do
that with his contract they're not doing
it with his contract
and so it's just it's two different team
building philosophies
and you know if you're 25 years old or
30 years old
and you're aaron rodgers then you know
maybe you're okay with the packers
building that
way but again if you look at it you say
we may only have two or three more shots
at this
well you know then you know i'm thinking
you know aaron's probably thinking
like i know i i want you to to mortgage
every contract on this roster
yeah so we can fit as many good people
in here as we possibly can so how's that
quote-unquote fixable
as uh my colleague james jones has
pointed out or john kuhn has said
publicly and we're we're using those
words to try and inform us about whether
this is in fact a fixable problem
between rogers in the front office free
agencies already history
i mean and then we heard about that the
conversation that rogers did not
personally uh restructure his contract
um was it made to was that something
that rogers might be
kind of uh uh disturbed with it being
termed that way when they could have
already triggered this thing anyway and
they come to him asking him for
a restructure is that is that yeah i
mean they don't need to i mean like i
said
like all they got to do is press that
button rich you know what i mean like
all they got to do is press that button
and
and the contracts restructured so you
know again they've got
like the odd they've got the negotiated
right to do that they haven't done it
and uh you know fixable yeah i i think
so so here's the way i look at it yes i
had a conversation with aaron rodgers
about this
a couple years ago and you know we
talked about him
falling in the draft and he said that
doesn't really motivate him anymore it's
like it's hard when you've had the
success that he's had
for that to motivate you anymore so his
new motivation
uh you know he said was i'm gonna play
as long i'm gonna see how long i
keep playing at this level and he
actually bought tom brady's book like
the tb12 method
and adopted some of the principles there
and so
you know i think like to me like what
would be an intelligent appeal would be
to go to aaron rodgers and say listen
like we want you back here we think
we've got a championship team right now
we've got a lot of guys
on the roster who are in the heart of
their prime we feel the need to win
right now
so the ship has sort of sailed on this
off season so there's nothing we can do
right now
let's give it a go with the team that we
have and then
we promise you that if you want you want
to keep playing and you're 38 now you
want to keep playing your 40s like brady
did
we will start to do some of the things
the buccaneers have done for brady
if they can do that open up the lines of
communication i think there's a path
there but i don't think it's going to
happen without a little give and it's
not just the contract the contracts are
part of it of course
you know and i think giving him the
assurance he'll be the quarterback for
the foreseeable future that of course is
a part of it
but i think also you know giving a
little bit on the way you build the team
i think would probably go a long way
with him so the bucks and the way that
they're doing it with brady
and being successful ultimately
successful at it
is just messing with the the greater
scheme of things
certainly in green bay oh yeah yeah i
mean not just that
seattle what about what about russell
wolfe you know what i mean like
right like and and and i don't think
that like i don't that's necessarily an
issue that's going to go away next year
you know what i mean like
i just think it's and and i guess you
can trace some of that to lebron and the
super teams right
like there's just you know i think
athletes are more cognizant of what's
going on around them than ever before
and the fact that the bucks built this
way and it worked
again that's the key to it and it worked
is a huge thing because now you know i
think quarterbacks gonna look at it and
say
i know what sort of leverage i have i'm
quasi management as it is if you're a
franchise quarterback that's what you
are
and i just you know the way i see it is
you know like
i don't i think this is the beginning
not the end of these things or starting
to have
the beginning not the end of these
things happening with franchise
quarterbacks
albert really appreciate the time thanks
so much you're
you're awesome thanks for the time and
let's uh let's chat again real soon
absolutely thanks rich appreciate the
insight right there at albert breer on
twitter at albert underscore breer on
instagram and of course check him out at
the mmqb
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here